hey guys over there in 15 today we are
unboxing the new DJI spark this is the
latest drone in DJ eyes lineup and as
you guys know I am a huge fan of drones
I've actually been playing with this one
for the past month or so the person that
I showed you before in a video was a
prototype version and it wasn't the
final retail version i preorder this
pretty much three seconds after it was
available and you pre-ordered early I
believe the only ones that you could get
were the white one but now it looks like
all the other colors are available so
there are several other colors there's
blue red yellow green and this one the
white the only color that I would have
got was hot pink or purple and they
didn't have those colors let's open this
bad boy up ages 15 plus so this is
actually the fly more package this comes
with the drone a carrying case charger
extra batteries and a controller it
released two separate versions there's
one that is just the drone itself that
allows you to be able to fly with just
your iPhone and this one that comes with
the controller and all of the
accessories so this is by far a much
better deal because you get everything
in one and also came with a SD card
don't cast the drone whoa this looks
like a lot of paperwork
like what could possibly be in here like
a novel oh I never thought I needed
reading glasses but I don't even think
reading glasses would help out with this
we need a freaking magnifying glass cool
sword let's open up the drone first
would not be something you feel like
there was another color in here that way
so it's like wow so good it's kind of
crazy I didn't even realize you put the
batteries in here and they fit perfectly
it's a beautiful drone and if you're
wondering yes I did match my nails to my
drone because would you expect anything
more or anything less of me so it's one
charge you should get approximately
sixteen minutes of flight time so the SD
card just goes right here in the back
and there's also a micro USB slot one of
the best things about the spark is
you're able to charge it via USB so if
you happen to only have a USB micro you
don't want to bring the additional
charger you don't have to you can charge
this through USB which is amazing
so this also comes with some extra
propellers alright let's see what's in
here now
let's show you how to pack it this is
all very nicely packed in here here is
your charger here's the prop guard power
cable this just plugs right into here
and like so if you're doing the palm
takeoff and landing it's definitely
recommended to use the prop guards
here's a controller so one of the main
differences between this controller and
the Mavic controller
there's no LCD display on this one I
actually haven't got a chance to fly the
spark with the controller yet so it's
going to be pretty cool to try to
actually use this because I'm getting
pretty used to fly with my iPhone which
is a whole different experience so
that's it for what's in our little bag
so actually win it back oh oh one of the
most important parts this is the
charging job and this is something that
is amazing because you can charge up to
three batteries at the same time one of
the worst parts about drones is their
battery life because they don't last
that long but it makes it super easy to
charge on the go you can also get
charging cables for your car one of the
main questions that I've been getting
more than anything is just seeing what
trollin do I get this is a really really
difficult question because if you're a
beginner I would definitely say get this
one the price point on the Mavic is much
higher than this but you also are
getting better video quality but this is
all
super small super simple it's way less
expensive than thematic is so it really
depends on your budget what are you
going to do with it and ultimately do
you need 4k or do you not need 4k
there's also a bunch of pre-programmed
flight modes in here so it really is a
social media drone in the palm of your
hand being able to do the palm takeoff
and palm landings it's pretty awesome
and you don't even need to use your
phone for it you can use palm control
you can direct your drill left/right
up/down you give it one of these symbols
and it takes your picture all without
needing to connect to your own okay
that's it let me know in the comments
below what you guys think of the sparks
you have a favorite drone do you have a
drone are you going to get a drone do
you want a drone I'll also leave a link
in the description and a card at the end
this video where you guys can see the
previous video that I made when I first
got my hands on one of these guys
there's some footage of me flying the
drone and there's also some
demonstrations of using the palm control
the palm takeoff and the palm landing I
will see you guys in my next video and
hopefully I will see you guys at VidCon
and super excited I will see you guys
very very soon
[Music]